so
i'm in the kitchen doing my kitchen work
and during a break
i sit on a crate now a guy
who has murdered two people in the
prison system
magpie will call him comes up to me
and says that's my seat get off it
right everyone looks
remember when i told you the gang rules
in part one
if someone calls you punk or hits you
or anything you must strike back
or else everyone's gonna prey on you so
if i get off that
seat now i'm a punk so this was your
first time
in that area so you didn't know that
that's where he typically sat or
something or what was that about
exactly okay i didn't even know whether
he was telling the truth
right you just you just you just knew
you couldn't follow his command
he was just trying to punk me out and i
could not follow his command
my decision criteria is this do i want
to have a problem with
everybody on the yard by being a punk or
do i have a problem with one person
even though that person has murdered two
people in prison
i think i would rather have a problem
with one person so stayed on the seat
so he starts kicking off he's saying
that
he's going to come to my cell and shank
me i'm going to be his third victim
and i've got a workout partner at that
time called iron man
who was trained highly trained in
martial arts and you can't do martial
arts in prison it's illegal
so there was like a room on the end of a
run
on the upper tier where we could go and
do yoga
and we were in there one night he's
teaching me martial arts
and there's a guard called the
bloodhound he's called the bloodhound
because
it was said he could smell hooch from a
hundred yards away
yeah so me and iron man are doing
martial arts and iron man's says that
magpie's got a steel rod in his leg
because he's been shot in prison by the
guards
so iron man wants me to do a snap kick
on the iron rod in this guy's leg
and then as he as he falls forward to um
put him out of action by going through
his eyeballs he's he's teaching me all
this stuff
but don't start the thing either that
i'll just gouge him or whatever
yeah so so he's teaching me these things
and um
we had a sense that something was
coming at us someone was approaching
and we didn't know what it was the
bloodhound he was coming to bust us if
you catch just doing martial arts
we'll get a disciplinary ticket a
write-up we'll lose our visit
we might get sent to lock down a prison
within a prison
all these bad things will happen so
all of a sudden we both jumped into tree
poles
in yoga so we're both just in tree pose
as the bloodhound jumps into the cell
and there's nothing he could do about
that because yoga is perfectly legal
oh my god yeah now every night after my
training with iron man
i'm getting more and more perplexed
because this thing's hanging over me
i just want the beef to be squashed
right so i said to iron man
why did i just steam into his room
have to fight and get it over with and
iron man said look
the cameras will show you've gone to his
room you'll be the aggressor
you're about to get released but if they
file street charges on you for going
into his room
you could get another five years onto
your sentence right
so every night i'm in my cell with my
sneakers on
just waiting for him to come in i'm just
gonna bounce up
and about he's mouthing off you know
he's going to do this he's going to do
that and eventually the people on the
yard said to him
if you don't go in and do something
after all this mouth enough
you're going to have to leave the yard
which means they're going to beat him up
and kick him off the yard
so one night he comes into my cell
and i jump up you know assume the
position
kind of turn a bit of an angle from him
ready to ready to throw
um a punch and stuff but he's got like a
look on his face and i'm trying to
figure it out
he doesn't look like he wants to fight
but maybe he's trying to suck a punch me
he got into how did he get in oh this is
this was like a yard where you could
just walk into people's cells
oh okay okay yeah yeah it just came up
the stairs walked longer tier and came
into my cell
so i jump up i'm ready
look at him he looks like he's not going
to get down but i'm thinking maybe he's
trying to trick me
into a false sense of security and then
he's going to just go bam bam
so i'm looking at him i'm saying what's
up
and he's like he said
that he's come to apologize
and so for what i said what and he goes
he said he was just clowning he said he
when he said he was going to kill me he
was just clowning
now i said to him i said
when someone who's killed two people in
the prison system tells
someone and their friends that they're
going to kill him
you know because of your history we're
not going to see that as clowning and
he's like yeah yeah
i understand that but but you know
i'm about to get released and if i kill
you
i could get the death penalty i'll never
get out i've already served 30 something
years wherever it was
he said that the guys he killed he
killed him when he first came in
it was either them or him it was
something he had to do
and he extended his sentence and he was
looking forward to getting out and then
he got a really sad look on his face
and he said um it goes england
all i know is heroin he goes
i've got money with that other business
but how am i going to survive all i know
is heroin
that's so you know like i said all the
all the day revolt
was getting the heroin and getting high
on heroin to forget about the troubles
and he looked at me and he knew i had a
female visiting me
and he asked me for help and i promised
him some help but he never followed
through
and in the end this guy i thought i was
gonna have to fight
it was maybe gonna try and stab me to
death
i saw i felt his pain right i felt his
heart open when he was looking at me
talking about the heroine
and i just felt the pain of everything
he'd been through for 40 years and
wondered what kind of horrible life he'd
had
and i completely reversed in that second
of my heart opening
from this guy being my my number one
enemy coming to kill me
to feeling sorry for the dude and that's
what it's like they've all got
even the most heinous um criminals who
do murders and stuff
they've all got behind every big crime
there's a horrific story of
child abuse that's what i've learned not
just from my prison experience
but from i've done over 100 podcasts now
on my channel
more than half of them gangsters and
criminals and um
a lot of them were abused as well one
one guy he went to
his best friend's house best friend
wasn't home
the dad said come in got him drunk and
raped him and he went to prison for
trying to kill that guy
and then when he went back to when he
got out of prison he went straight to
that guy's house and tried to kill him
again
and then again he kept doing it and
doing it until he exploded and stopped
his friend
and ended up in prison for that as well
so
this is something that this abuse
trajectory
is something that it's like he wants to
improve we really need to start helping
these young people who are suffering
yeah i know i know that's a vast
majority of of the people that are in
there
um but it's so interesting how
there is just this fascination with
these types of people
in pop culture and in the media you know
what i mean especially when they're when
they're murderers
like there's so many documentaries for
example and i think
one of like the key things i don't know
if you've noticed this
or if you've done a lot of studying on
this but the people who
go through not necessarily child
trauma or child abuse but
they don't get that connection when
they're in that infant stage
like for ex like just for an example uh
ted kaczynski
how i just watched this documentary and
it they talk about how when he was an
infant he basically
broke out in hives and had to go to the
hospital for like months and months and
months and when he came back
after without they wouldn't allow his
parents to visit him more than an hour a
week
and when he came back he just was like
gone like he was just like
he would stare off into space he had
gone from like this bubbly happy little
kid to just like
nobody's home he lost all his empathy he
lost his
moral compass and that guy was
pretty [ __ ] smart considering he was
in harvard by the age of 16
and doing all this stuff and
you know the people like that like that
guy had a cult following
from prison you know the stuff that he
talked about or whatever he had sort of
like developed this
massive group of people that worshipped
him how many people did you
run into if any in prison or
after prison that were you would
consider
true psychopaths oh my goodness i've
known
psychopaths before prison in prison and
after prison
and i think the psychopathy is highest
when they are
youngest and then it mellows out and
they find ways
to make alliances with people
and they just you know become more
strategic rather than
brute force in your face violence
so two tonys was an example you know um
as a younger person
on the cocaine just whacking people
and not thinking twice you know um
just just looked at it as a as a
business transaction
uh kind of thing um some of these
mafia guys see it as the same as being
in the military
you're signing up to something where
you're going to kill or be killed
but then you've got you know i've never
associated with the complete
psychopathic monsters who would
just torture and kill kids and
women and stuff like that i've never
associated or met
um anybody like that who like pre like
planned out their murders
you know what i mean like like thought
like i'm gonna they plan them out
perfectly like this is gonna be the
perfect
person i'm gonna kill and i'm gonna
write a journal about every single kill
like it's like this
well two tony's detailed all of his
methods of killing and body disposal
to me and they're in his book the mafia
philosopher two tonys which is on amazon
and um he you know
he would burn all of his clothes
afterwards they'd have plastic sheets
um they'd get rid of the gun it was all
done
rather meticulously but
he had problems getting rid of bodies
because he whacked people from
arizona to alaska and
in certain parts of the world depending
upon the temperature the body will
decompose and rot away but the bodies in
alaska
they didn't the birds didn't eat them
they were hoping the birds would eat one
and it didn't eat it and it just
remained in the cold temperature and the
cops found it
and two tony said that
you know the various methods of body
disposal
one was you dig a deep hole
bury the body and then you put a dead
animal over the body so many feet higher
because when the cadaver dog comes out
it'll hit on the animal and then they'll
stop digging to find the human corpse
but but even better invest in funeral
homes which is what the banana crime
family did
who two tonys worked for so two tonys
came on up under
um charlie bats battaglia who was a
lieutenant for the banana crime family
and charlie bats battaglia had whacked
people from coast to coast
and got rid of bodies and was an expert
and never never been caught for any of
that
so he passed that information down to
two tonys
and that's how he learned to get away
with these things
you